ces sénatoriales sonne-t-elle le glas
des réformes institutionnelles souhaité
par emmanuel macron pour les faire voter
à l'assemblée et au sénat
il aura besoin d'une majorité des trois
cinquièmes sur l'ensemble des deux
chambres
les projections donnent à la république
en marche 20 à 30 sénateurs
or 160 serait nécessaire pour atteindre
la majorité
ça fera donc 130 à 140 députés ou
sénateurs à convaincre mission pas
complètement impossible mais difficile
la logique même de la constitution c'est
d'exiger que il y ait le consensus le
plus large possible
nous sommes en démocratie ce consensus
suppose donc que des contraires se
mettre d'accord
voici les principales réformes qui
devront obtenir cette fameuse majorité
des trois cinquièmes la rénovation de la
procédure parlementaire
la suppression de la cour de justice de
la république
la réforme du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature et du conseil économique et
social et enfin la limitation du cumul
des mandats dans le temps
c'est cette dernière réforme qui risque
d'être un point de crispation notamment
avec les sénateurs des républicains il
ya un point dur c'est la limitation du
nombre de mandats dans le temps parce
que effectivement ça peut poser une
véritable difficulté de principe
en revanche les autres sujets comme
notamment la suppression de la cour de
justice de la république ou un système
législatif beaucoup plus efficace et
beaucoup plus rapide si cela est
nécessaire nous sommes ouverts à ça le
sénat fera lui aussi des propositions
la majorité sénatoriale et propositions
en espérant que le gouvernement les
entendre si obtenir cette majorité se
révèle impossible reste une solution
le référendum le gouvernement ne semble
pas l'exclure sur et à organiser un
référendum sur ces mesures là il n'a pas
de majorité
il est l'inventaire il l'a dit lui même
c'est un engagement qu'il a pris comme
candidat à la présidence et nous
souhaitons le tenir
mais en cas de référendum le
gouvernement devrait d'abord soumettre
le texte de réforme dans les mêmes
termes à l'assemblée et on y revient au
sénat